هذه اثار القصف الاسرائيلي الذي طال منزل
يتبع لعائله قاسم فجر هذا اليوم جهود
الاهالي مستمره لانتشال ما تبقى من جثامين
الشهداء اسفل هذه الانقاظ ما يقارب 50
مفقودا اسفل هذه الانقاظ حتى هذه اللحظه
الكثير من الاطفال والنساء كل هذا البيت
كان ثلاث عائلات نازحه مكون هذا
البيت من ثلاث طوابق تم تدميره بالكامل
والان الجهود لاخ هذه الجثامين على الرغم
من الوضع الصعب وقله الامكانات مدنيين
هولنا
80 راحوا
كلتهم
استش هذه جهود الاهالي واهالي المنطقه
لاستخراج ما تبقى من جثامين الشهداء ولس
في شهداء تحت الانقاد احنا مش قادرين لا
في ر ولا في غاز انه نجيب اليات ونطلع من
تحت الركام شهداء اسرائيل تمارس الضغط على
كل من عنده الات
الات حاول كباج او معدات قويه لانقاذ
الاحياء تهاجمها بالضرب هددت كل من يتحرك
باله كجراح
باقر معدات الازاله ان تقصفها ح بما فيها
تستمر جهود الاهالي لانتشال الجثام لكن
المحاولات دائما تكون صعبه في ظل نقص
الامكانات اسماعيل الغول قناه الجزيره
مدينه غزه